[Music]
had this idea Dottie life was just gonna
be just easy breezy what has been the
best thing about doing this reality show
and what has been the hardest thing
about it that thing
I mean we've gotten to spend a lot of
time together and I think that also
sometimes to be like the worst thing in
a way because we haven't really had our
space and both of us are really
independent people because you're
essentially working together and living
together that's tough it's not I don't
think that's healthy um you know for any
relationship I'd say that's probably the
hardest part is there going to be a
season two you know honestly like as we
sit here now we don't know we're trying
to just like with the wedding and just
like everything in life take it one step
at a time right now at this point open
to doing a season two
we're both open to any opportunity that
comes I don't think we will ever say no
before something if it comes to fruition
you know um so until that comes our way
then we'll discuss we're happy that
we're together and we'll see without the
where that takes us don't you think it's
better just to slow all of this down you
were talking wedding dates the wedding's
on hold right now at this point are you
talking wedding dates again
um um again honestly like it is on hold
we haven't necessarily discussed an
exact wedding day um we we had an idea
of you know kind of when we wanted to
and now it's kind of does that work for
where life's going for us um so we're on
hold with that it's not but we talked
wedding along if she if there's a theme
or there's a dress she sees he's still
gonna talk about it dates specifically
we have
[Music]
you